questo rumore si fa strada dando
qualcosa in faccia diceva che
si dimostri freedom e
via libera
[Musica]
veniamo storico siamo in un mostro dirlo
blocks proibito e cioè le stanze
proibite di rho blocks non so se ne
avete già sentito parlare ma si chiamano
le boe cruz inter io dicono che non
potremo neanche registrare qua delle
reflex ma lui
registriamo la testa
allora che cosa sono le boe cruz c'è
tutta una leggenda su queste stanze
proibite ma vediamo prima assieme che
cosa riusciamo a trovare qua perché dice
il teletrasporto e infatti non lo so e
non lo sta parte meglio non mi sono
preso questa la porta io mi son messo la
tuta contro al materiale pericoloso
ok non so che cosa troveremo in queste
non si sa mai ci sono varie leggende
dietro a queste becca un saputo è solo
quest presto sbrigati entra
[Musica]
le varie leggende dicono tipo che queste
sono le stanze in cui finisce tipo se
c'è un bug nel sistema finisci o
trappola altri allora se stanno così non
camminare su quelle cose nere perché ti
tolgono la vita io sono 55 e poi c'è
anche la leggenda delle boe cruz prima
di rob lowe comunque ci sono varie
leggende sulle boe cruz anzi se volete
conoscere qualcuna scrivetecelo nei
segmenti perché potete sapere tutti i
segreti di queste stanze strade io o
meglio se mi metto a seguire te perchè
ho paura di perdermi inerme la prima
mente gli im perderai allora abbiamo
preso degli oggetti formato plastica
bene cosa dobbiamo fare ma insomma il
pagherà ma per favore cerchiamo degli
oggetti e vediamo se riusciamo a uscire
da queste back room crisi sarebbe ancora
meglio scoprire tutti i segreti e
svelare insomma il mistero di queste
stanze proibite e soprattutto perché
sono proibite che cosa nascondono
esattamente e perché sembra tutto uguale
ma per quello che secondo po troppa
paura di perdermi esistano dei rumori
strani forse sta arrivando qualcuno
oppure forse stato stanno lavorando al
piano di sopra
ora ho un'idea seguiva di altri
giocatori ma per voi che sanno dove
andare bene ho trovato una porta
chiudi
figo in un ascensore eh sì ma non si
muove forse forse lo può essere possiamo
utilizzare per nasconderci se c'è un
pericolo nasconderci da chi o da cosa
questo rumore si fa strada un qualcosa
che faccia ce lo diceva che la storia
per cui i denti dei mostri quelli
sbrigati ad uscire come vedi
la potenza è stata tagliata nella
struttura forse anche della corrente è
stato per la struttura ma cosa c'è tra
shrek nelle back room se per chi sa
essere cattivo e cerca quella mano
che stavo urlando
per crescere come uscire anche super
simpatico forse se si direbbe
bravo hai perso la morte mi ha preso la
lega ha prezzo io preferisca tu perché
verso la porta quando nel rugby non
capisco sono due ace 3 sei cattivo
perché è diventato cattivo ma forse
perché queste beckham se le cose si
comportano in modo diverso e ti do un no
e ti posso io c'erano mosso incubo sono
un mostro sul nostro
aiuto mi sta seguendo il vostro non mio
ha una faccia bianca
allora i clienti con l'ultima ma l'ho
visto si stanno iniziando la cosa strana
in queste back room che non sono stati
smettano di seguirmi di freddo e anche
me anche tu sei in seguito dagli stress
nodo questa faccia con i denti e gli
occhi bianchi
bastata per via
[Musica]
vicolo cieco sì anche vero
che sta mordendo se non lo so che sto
facendo poco ho paura di rimanere
intrappolata qual è la tecnica che
cosa era quel rumore vediamo se trovo
qualche oggetto fa
e tutto molto strano
dobbiamo riuscire a scoprire il mistero
è il segreto di queste cose che cosa
sono sono in tempo reale sono un sogno
sono un incubo stallone riferimento
creata da qualcuno o ho trovato qualcosa
trappola goccia sa bene prendi anche
esserci utile però come facciamo a
trovare la via di un unica è sottoposto
tre lissimo o no no no no ho già trovato
un mostro quale quello bianco si è
scoperto che si può anche correre
davvero con che cosa vedi premuto shift
i sensi
sono tantissimi e
che cos'è qui potrebbe solo trappola qui
ok attento non farti spiaccicare dal
nella stessa trappola quella l'ira e la
trappola questa qui vedi dove ci sono io
stato la tv
è però ancora non è passato il muro non
abbiamo tirarlo qua e catturato si ok
allora appena mi rincorre tornerò lì per
farlo prendere ok io sento dei rumori
sta arrivando scaricando qualcuno dice
che shaq qui ok porterò la trappola ok
ghiacci chiama sono troviamo non mi
ricordo vero la trappola in una trappola
qui tema quei dove dove ci sono io no
ho trovato soubrette
e cos'è il succo di frutta sarà ma non
sta pensando del mostro
la macchina dopo blu no penso che ti a
quel morto nella sorta di fantasma ho
trovato una bussola e adesso che cosa ci
faccio con la bussola
[Musica]
abbiamo dovuto ricominciare perché in
gioco ci ha buttato secondo sia un'altra
delle cose strane delle black room
sono passata da un altro passaggio
davvero però vediamo cosa troviamo qua
filo elettrico per inaspetta mi dovete
uscite fuori teneramente il coraggio
mostro lasciami piazza perché sono
quelli qui ci parlo a fette ma noi
dobbiamo intrappolarli credo non mi
sembra che per me questo corridoio
sembra che le cose stiano ma pensiamo
mia uomini forse cambiano dopo un tot di
tempo un po come le scale di harry
potter
periodo che stai le scale piace cambiare
ricordate
e infatti qua ho appena trovato uno
scheletro uno scheletro e isterico e man
2 molto strani gli oggetti che si
trovano poco amato fucile
ok usalo appena arriva qualche mostro mi
raccomando lasciate un bel mi piace qua
se volete che facciamo un altro episodio
di scopriamo tutti i segreti delle boe
cruz per il lettiano anche tutte le
storie riguarda l becks e vi raccontiamo
tutti i segmenti non ti trova sono
ritrovata qua ho paura che le boe cruz
mi abbiano intrappolato qua perché non
trovo più una via d'uscita è che ci sia
un codice che codice 59 83
ricordiamocelo key 59 8.33 vita per
paura perché dove sei non lo so è tutto
strano qui non dirlo a me io sono
incastrata quale attacco di
metallo beh prima o poi si serviranno a
qualcosa tutti questi oggetti no devo
dire io ho trovato dall'altro legno devo
dire però che sembrano tutte uguali ma
in realtà trovo sempre delle cose
differenti sembra che giriamo intorno ma
in realtà non stiamo andando sempre in
posti diversi credo
[Musica]
c'è un rumor è arrivato qualcuno credo
di sì
potenza è stato tagliato alla struttura
bene anche al buio diventa ancora più
inquietante così ok io mi nascondo
aspetto più in un corridoio
[Musica]
non capisco dove sto andando ma
soprattutto dove sono gli altri
giocatori non c'è nessuno qua
ci sono un sacco di altri giocatori che
stanno giocando eppure non lasciano solo
nessuno infatti si è anche a trovare
vitale a qualcuno può ripristinare la
corrente
non lo so
aiuto
ok giornata sì ma c'è qualcuno che ci
sto cercando uno dei mostri dai dobbiamo
scoprire il segreto di queste back room
almeno riuscire a uscire da qua ciao ho
trovato un giocatore qui ma io sono un
altro uomo gli anche altri giocatori che
mi possono compagnia ebbene c'è un
giocatore che dice che ha eliminato o
però attivi nei punti vero noi un mese
zero quindi è possibile eliminarli
dobbiamo trovare il modo di eliminarli
bussola sì l'avevo trovata prima però
non ho capito che la società prossima ci
aiuterà a scappare si beh sì se solo
sapesse dove devo andare di fondare nord
ovest est come faccio a capirlo ho vinto
uno scheletro che devo fare come scalo
trovata anch'io prima fanno una corto e
jade quito per l'appunto lo scheletro
era così il codice il 79 84 era diverso
forse ci stiamo avvicinando la soluzione
dobbiamo mettere a segno qualche parte
faccio nata questa sequenza
[Musica]
cerca mista altrimenti dove si dai
no no no nuovo test a parte lo
noti appreso
anch'io le batterie
provato tante cose che cosa sono sia un
mostro bruttissima torre non ottimo
tutto nero
è meglio non entrare adesso
vorrei controllare il mio c'è un sacco
di cose guardate che mostra è questo
stranissimo sembra fi permesso
ho messo male finito eliminato tutti
davvero ma io sono ancora qui forse
riesco a farlo entrare nella trappola
primo trovi di quote nel coraggio cara
nostra non deve mai
niente non arriva il mostro con troppo
ok allora in cerca di vitale adesso sì
vediamo se riusciamo a trovarlo per
sulla teca o meno sono i corridoi di
evitare la trappola quale trappola alla
trappola per la ii e di chi si ricorda
come fare ad avere dei fatti tutto un
labirinto ho trovato anche il proprio
fucile
bene ora non mi fanno più paura
[Musica]
e ora non mi fanno più paura è mostrata
beccati questo
ei perché non funziona
non ci credevo che fuggire perché non ha
funzionato
ok la mia tecnica questa volta sarà
seguire gli altri giocatori
questo funziona male sia ancora il
mostro vediamo se loro sanno dove andare
per lippi forse io stato fatto ha
trovato purtroppo
procedendo produrre allora c'è il mostro
nero qui aiuto
capiamo
trova girarvi dove sei in un corridoio
acqua di pandor le è che cosa me ne
faccio è buono ripescato disse basta
prendere più vita è uno sprecata non
moralmente si sa c'è qualcuno ok
continuiamo a seguirli
se qualche mostro politico
aiuto
abbiamo ora lo so dove soro ma solo in
una parte dove non c'era nessuno neanche
i mostri
un po morde ho sentito qualcuno che
faceva a fette qualcuno
li uccidiamo ci fa ben 6
segniamo tutte le porte i nostri con
fuori lo vedete ma vedrete il seguito
che piedi di tanto
tanto qua non può prendersi credo sto
vedendo limitarti dove sei
ehi tu non aprire la porta mi raccomando
eh non fare come fatto tu prima con me
ho trovato il plutonio è debole cosa
dobbiamo fare il plutonio
io stavo in trappola con dentro perché
il nostro non va via col pronuncia anche
[Musica]
ok
via libera
al minuto di partita
ma perché truffa
oggi sono sei
che hanno preso sì
[Musica]
no
lasciate un bel vediamo se volete che
continuiamo il mistero gente the groms
assicuratrici commenti se voi sapete
fare la forza di questo ministero e ora
mi lasciavo 4 adesso diretto pubblicare
per vedere i nostri altri video l'età
scolare preferite
ciao